caitlyn jenner whom i've met wonderful
person
caitlyn jenner
was voted
woman of the year
her first year as a woman ain't that
something beat every [ __ ] in detroit
she's better than all of you
never even had a period ain't that
something
oh i'd be mad as [ __ ] if i was a woman
i'd be mad if i was me if i was in a bet
awards sitting there and they're like in
the winter for [ __ ] of the year
eminem
and i found these notebooks and i
started going through the notebooks and
it was all this wonderful poetry in him
written as his handwriting i didn't even
know this [ __ ] wrote poems
and then i looked through his drawers
and i opened up his middle drawer
and i found this rolling paper
and i look down at them papers like oh
that's where that poetry is coming from
[Applause]
and that [ __ ] broke my heart
i mean i smoke weed but i mourned my
son's innocence
and i cried a little bit
and i took his papers upstairs to my
room
[Applause]
rolled some weed that i'd hit from the
family and i got really high
and then i got paranoid
so i put his papers back how i found him
but
let me qualify the statement i i am
what's known on the streets as a victim
blamer
you know what i mean somebody come up to
me like dave dave chris brown just beat
up rihanna i'd be like well what did she
do
[Applause]
dang michael jackson was molesting
children well what were those kids
wearing at the time
[Applause]
i don't think he did it
well you know what
even if he did do it
you know what i mean
you know what i mean
i mean it's michael jackson
i know more than half the people in this
room have been molested in their lives
but it was no goddamn michael jackson
wasn't
you know america has a racial hot seat i
think we can all agree that that's the
truth
and we can also agree that that hot seat
is traditionally occupied by
african-americans in general
african-american men in particular
although i can see that in recent years
that seat has been occupied by
by mexicans
and i dare say arabs
and we the black americans would like to
thank you both for your sacrifice and
your struggle
we needed a break
we needed a goddamn break
we all go through something but at least
i can leave my backpack someplace
if you are up and forget the backpack
you got about 20 minutes
before they send that robot to blow your
[ __ ] up
then i thought of an idea for a
children's book
the book is designed to help parents
teach their children about racism which
if you're a parent you know is an
impossible concept to teach to a child
the book is about a big strong beautiful
black man
with a benign regular-ass white name and
he has a white speaking voice whenever
this [ __ ] calls to get a
reservation at a restaurant oh he gets
the reservation that name and that voice
who could resist them now i should tell
you this black man is literally an
actual giant he's a strong dude and when
he shows up to them restaurants they see
that big giant black dude they say you
can't come in here and and they call the
police and in every installment of the
book the police come and they always
shoot them but remember no no remember
this guy is a giant these bullets don't
kill him they don't even hurt them
they just break his heart
it's called clifford the big black
[ __ ]
[Music]
all our stars
all our stars man
our kelly pissed on his victim
i know it was rough but i mean again i
can't even judge r kelly first of all we
don't know if these allegations are true
or not even if they are true if you want
to know how i feel about it honestly
if a man cannot pee on his fans
i don't want to be in show business
anymore because well that's why i got in
the game baby i got dreams too
you guys are confusing the issue while
you guys are busy worrying about if r
kelly even peed on this girl or not
you're not asking yourself the real
question that america needs to decide
once and for all and that question is
how old is 15 really
no that's a good question
that's a good question
i'm not saying that a person is as smart
as they're going to be at 15. that's not
what i'm saying man but i am saying
15 to me
is old enough to decide
whether or not you want to be pissed on
i mean that's me
if you can't make a decision like that
by the time you're 15 and just give up
[ __ ] because life is way harder
than that
i make tougher decisions all the time if
you don't want to get pissed on just get
the [ __ ] out of the way it's not even a
decision if i stop peeing on the front
row they're not gonna have to calculate
and think how do i feel about this am i
okay with it they just move
you can do that at 15. i could have i've
been 15. when i was 15 i was doing
stand-up and nightclubs i smoked reefer
from time to time friends were selling
crack i was trying to finger [ __ ] people
i knew what was happening around me
to some degree
getting pissed on was the least of my
worries at 15.
trust me
but it keeps coming up it's a lot of
confusion around that age any time 15
comes up people freak out like when that
girl elizabeth smart got kidnapped
right
remember utah last year's 15-year-old
girl elizabeth smart was kidnapped and
then they finally found her and the
whole country was relieved and i was the
only one saying damn she wasn't that
smart after all
now cause she got kidnapped that could
happen to anybody i'm not knocking her
for that i'm just saying if you're
kidding at me when i was 15
you gotta take me further than eight
miles away from my house man god damn
can't hold me prison around [ __ ] i
recognize i'll break away i'll break
away [ __ ] off me [ __ ] that's my bus
stop i know where i'm at i'm going home
she was missing for six months eight
miles away from my house that's two
exits man that's nothing
and while she was missing during this
half a year that this girl was missing
there's a seven-year-old black girl gets
kidnapped in philadelphia
nobody knows her name they might have
talked about it two or three times on
the news but she should have been top
story
because she chewed through the ropes and
had both of these [ __ ] in jail
and 45 minutes flat 7 years old
i'm not making this up
these two crackheads kidnapped and took
her back to the crack house and tied her
up
and then they left her the crackheads
they got to make moves crack smoke
chocolate to eat these [ __ ]
made moves it was out
but as soon as they left this little
girl got the nibbling
she was kidnapped at four o'clock and at
home watching herself on the news at 5
30. that [ __ ] is crazy
that's a that's a news story
that is a news story
now
meanwhile in utah
15 year old elizabeth smart's captains
left her alone too and they didn't even
tie her up because they're hillbillies
they just bounced don't try to escape
[ __ ] it will kill you be right back
at least
she's 15 sitting in the house by herself
how am i gonna get out of this
come on elizabeth think
think elizabeth how am i going to get
out of here
why don't you just open the [ __ ] door
and go outside have you thought about
that
do you have a quarter do you know your
phone number your 15 [ __ ] run stop
thinking and stop making moves
[Applause]
i know i sound mean and i know what the
people are thinking when i'm saying this
dave she is only 15.
all right but that's the discrepancy
because when you talk about a little
girl like elizabeth smart then the
country feels like 15 is so young and so
innocent
on the flip side here comes 15 again now
we talking about a 15 year old black kid
in florida this black kid accidentally
killed his neighbor when he's practicing
wrestling moves that he saw on tv now
was he a kid no they gave him life they
always tried our 15 year olds as adults
[ __ ] know what he was doing
it's a goddamn pile driver
this kid gets on the ropes there's no
stopping him
you'd have to send a rock to arrest him
and they gave a 15-year-old boy
life in jail
if you think that it's okay to give him
life in jail then it should be legal to
pee on them that's all i'm saying you
got to make up your mind across the
board how old 15 actually is that's all
i'm saying
so i'm gonna tell you right now if
somebody comes in here and puts a gun in
my head and says chappelle you got a
choice to make
you're either going to jail for a month
or we'll let you go
but you got to let our kelly pee on you
i'm not hesitating
bringing our kelly and tell him to stay
away from my eyes
i'd rather get pissed on on the outside
and [ __ ] the butt on the inside son
i can't go to jail with some smooth
botox balls and think everything's gonna
be all right it's not that kind of place
take my chance with that pistol wash off
with a 10 minute shower i'm certain of
it
coming right out
what can i do they're going to put me in
jail
[Applause]